[Music]
in no privacy news submitted by Pat
Iguchi mm-hmm an anonymous person is
claiming to have facial recognition
texting cross reference women's photos
on social media with faces from porn oh
is this for deep fakes so deep fakes
well they were taking normal people
putting it on poor things but now it oh
let me find this porn actresses actual
Facebook page Oh dog fur kind of thing
what how does that work so they can face
recognized on the porno and I'll search
yeah hosted on a Chinese social network
Weibo they they are claiming that they
have used facial recognition to
cross-reference through all social media
and they also claim that they have
successfully identified more than one
hundred thousand ladies in the adult
industry on a global scale
if porn was legal in China porn stars
would be billionaires oh yeah they'd be
still ballin oh yeah why because it's
porn is illegal over there so they're
not making money off the internet
available in China is [ __ ] dude I
couldn't [ __ ] use the Wi-Fi to save
my life when I was at the layover yeah
like they you could connect to their
Wi-Fi but the only thing you could use
is nothing like what people what
websites people can see in stuff you
can't do anything you can't go on you
can't Facebook can you use like a bpm
I was posting on Instagram when I was in
China yeah I couldn't let Instagram as a
facebook company maybe they allow
Instagram but not Facebook I was just
using the roaming data stuff you know I
was in Shenzhen Chinchin about was it
[ __ ] I wonder how they do that dirt
farm China I don't know where was but it
was like just [ __ ] couldn't use
anything yeah they probably use like IP
blockers or whatever because porn is
illegal there but they find a way well
yeah obviously they found a way because
they yeah did this or they're claiming
to have done this because it hasn't been
completely verified yet and so she can't
get between a guy in his porn like he
would become a hacker just so he could
watch porn
they say that's why that's what further
technology and the internet was before
an industry yeah I wouldn't doubt it
yeah so this person who's claiming to
have done this they're saying that they
are a germany-based Chinese programmer
so that's why they're able to do that
okay
but you said that they didn't he this
person developed this because the goal
is to help others check whether their
girlfriend's ever acted in a porn who
cares what the [ __ ] you have to double
check okay yeah like oh this is to help
the guys out there to make sure your
girlfriend's yeah so before you marry
them so you know if they were what the
[ __ ] yeah I'd be happier
yeah cause like I guess there's a lot of
amateur porn stuff and so they were like
oh that's my wife I didn't know it's so
weird that makes me so annoyed
everybody's a [ __ ] Amercia porn star
no yeah we just literally just record
something and put it up fell in love
with someone it wouldn't matter if you
really felt oh no I don't like that [ __ ]
all right
I find out that your rear just [ __ ]
just downing a [ __ ] all day I don't know
about that yeah but then I mean then if
the girl didn't tell you that before you
fell in love with her then you have
trust issues not porn issues issue and
then not only that but then they're also
saying that that's that's crazy because
what if these women are victims of
revenge porn yeah where they like
without their consent completely
different because then I would be very
happy because I'll take that clip and
then I'll do what's revenge porn is when
the ex-boyfriend or I don't think he
realized what he said yeah I think I
just realized it right now that is
that's like when the ex boyfriend or
husband releases like a have like nudie
stuff yeah like price time oh yeah you
can go to jail for that stuff though
yeah here yeah there's a kid who was on
tumblr I think we did an article here he
was doing here like a revenge thing site
or something
blur or some like that and he went to
jail for like 20 years Wow okay she was
underage or something or something
scumbag yeah
that's all funny just in case you don't
trust your girl she like you know what I
have this feeling that my girl is she
was a porn star and I need to get to the
bottom of this like who what fix this
[ __ ] she's too pretty to not have been a
porn star no I thought it was gonna go a
different direction like the goal is to
help people to make sure that they
haven't been victims or revenge for
something like that but it's like to
make sure your woman has never been in
porn before you marry her yeah well
that's funny because then after you
changed his his whole approach like the
goal he did end up saying that like also
then you can check have you been a
victim or how he said initially it was
how many people are suspicious that
their girl was in a porn right cuz
they're you know I've been noticing
there is a lot of amateur porn out there
now yeah I'm just like a lot of people
look like porn stars they look like
normal people now and I'm like man what
is it words just like where's this live
stop coming from yeah there's also like
satellite like fetish porn like where
it's not really porn porn it's just like
women doing fetish things with their
tits out oh like eating food to eat on
it and like stomping on things like that
yeah like where it's not like porn bored
but it's a niche for tickling yeah yeah
scary I feel like any anybody who takes
like a nude photo of himself on their
[ __ ] phone it's just like aren't you
scared that somebody's gonna get into
this right yeah I've never done it don't
do that do that [ __ ] anymore cuz like
everybody what I don't get I don't know
I'm trying to get into these guys heads
cuz it's like okay if you know that your
girl's not a virgin already he's already
[ __ ] but now there's just a camera
attached to it what's the difference
what like she was special to you he's
not special to everyone maybe because
for them if there's now an exchange of
money it makes it different now because
before you were doing it for love and
that's what naturally happens between a
man and a woman but now that you're
doing it for profit
then you're immoral it's also public so
everyone could see your girl [ __ ]
like I think that one is what would
propose to my girlfriend what's like she
could give your friend a lap dance and
there's nothing you could do about it
yeah
like damn it but I need you to pay the
bills oh that's like a cup yeah exact
that pouring where it's like I need to
pay the rent so I gotta get my
girlfriend [ __ ] the landlord this juice
makes such good money they make it their
talented wife when I was when was I
flying to but I was meeting up but I was
a stripper or seven foods I was sitting
next to a stripper right she is so
[ __ ] pocketed but she kind of gave me
a breakdown about how much she makes or
how much strippers make on average I
thought the club actually takes a fatter
percentage than I thought they did they
don't they I think she told me they take
like ten ten percent ten to twenty
percent which is not much yeah don't
they do it like a hairdresser style
where they just kind of rent the space
and they they'll take that whatever fee
yeah but then it's super nominal and I'm
talking about like a like a lap dance
they'll make like a hundred bucks and so
they'll just break off like months off
of that to the club which is not much at
all and on top of that they're not like
on to us like every little Brandon where
you get a net 30 they get that whatever
they make that day they walk away with
that day oh that makes sense because
they're gonna attract customers so you
want the hottest girls and you don't
want to make them charge them arm and
leg to perform there and then they make
a lot of money off the alcohol so it's
like win-win well here you can't buy
alcohol if it's a full nude bar but if
it's a titty bar yeah yes
so if it's full nude its no alcohol but
if if its boobs allow if it's only boobs
yeah and like how that relationship
works - they'll they'll make sure that
they'll tip off the either the club
owner - or the DJ because then they'll
get more like stage time or whatever and
they'll give him the better music yeah
yeah so that's how it kind of works
because she was she was telling me on
average because she used to work as a
phlebotomist and that she stopped that
because she wasn't making enough money
so she started doing stripping instead
and on average depending on how much she
works and she says she sets up her
schedule like a job job but she was
doing it like a regular job so she
breaks off like just cash alone and
averagely a lot of smart women and paid
for their college that way yeah four
grand a three grand a week it's like yo
and they she said that mondays are the
hottest days for strip clubs
why because they're sad cuz I gotta go
to work yeah she says Mondays are the
hot days and she says she'll walk away
with three or four grand and she's lazy
she'll walk away with like 1,500 to like
a grand and I thought it would be the
weekend or something that's what I
thought too but she says Monday's the
hottest day huh
the men go back and they spend time with
family or something again oh and there
was something new but be imagine that
three to four grand a [ __ ] week dude
yeah but mine she says like if it's
three to four grand she's she's
exhausted I'm not gonna call Mondays in
your market to pass
she said she's exhausted but [ __ ] I feel
like a restaurant where you tip out the
bartender and the and the bussers and
stuff like that's not bad it's [ __ ]
crazy like it's amazing I was like yeah
I probably wouldn't go back to that [ __ ]
either if I'm making that much money
yeah it just blows my mind how much
money guys spend on just looking at
women yeah or just seeing their body
that's just crazy is there a guy
equivalent of that you know like girls
you know like no matter who I never
spend money whatever job he has it all
goes to [ __ ] you know if you want to
make six figures it's crime don't be a
stripper right guys is there that
equivalent where like if all goes to
[ __ ] and you want to make six figures be
a stripper you just gotta be fine as
[ __ ] or really tighten your clientele
might be mostly like guys yeah yeah yes
like I'd like a desperate job like like
being a ho like you know for girls like
you know like huh yeah but that's still
legal though like in California being a
gigolo is legal no he's asking if
there's a legal Oh like a legal lawyer
or you're right all goes to [ __ ]
panhandling no I think first I guess I
think for guys it's dangerous jobs like
crab fishermen or whatever I see that
because you get paid pretty high you're
doing that but the death rate is like
high so like working at an oil rig like
I think dangerous jobs is the guys
equipment like it's like
life-threatening
it's like coal mining [ __ ] or whatever
you know that's the equivalent to
stripping yeah cuz for girls you know
what's the desperate job where all else
fails but you could work it legally yeah
you become a stripper and you can still
make bank
legally and you don't need a license you
don't have to go back to school you
don't need any additional like
certifications I wonder if there's the
same for guys we're all [ __ ] fails I
still need to make six figures this is
what I do cuz that's a pretty sweet
[ __ ] deal yeah
just to go from I mean three to four
grand a week I mean obviously like I
mentioned before that's not every week
that happens yeah but
it's possible to make that much
depending on how many hours she ain't at
she's so she hasn't she had a strip club
that she works out here in LA on a
regular but then she'll also go to
different clubs to switch off depending
on what time they're popping
so her Monday Club she knows that this
one's popping on a Monday all the time
so she'll go there and then she'll go to
another one she'll audition at that Club
and then she'll do that but I guess like
she on average is working late [ __ ]
like 60 hours a week though but she has
a kid as well so she's transport the
kids oh like Vegas coming out or
whatever yeah that's crazy man
[Music]
[Music]